so it's 11 days till the European
elections here you can be mating for I'm
gonna vote labor and I make the case in
the article this morning as to why you
you can't because in the end there are
some great Labor candidates who are very
staunch early Pro remain I think the
basic soul of the party is is with
remain but what I'm saying is the
important thing is to vote so I do come
across a lot of labour people that
simply can't vote for labour at the
moment in which case I say them don't
stay at home go and vote for one of the
avowedly remain parties because what
will matter is at the end of this
election there's going to be a totting
up there's gonna be a ledger on one side
of the ledger to go will go mister Faraj
and his fellow travelers like Forrest
Johnson in the Conservative Party and on
the other side are going to be those
that are anti that position anti Faraj
and he brags it and it's important that
it's not so much the seats but the
percentage of the votes it's important
because MPs will then make their
decision as to what they do in
Parliament it's important that that anti
brexit side of the ledger is stronger
than the pro for outside I'm just trying
to work out how you can put labour on
the anti brexit side of the ledger yeah
and they have said that they only
support a second referendum to stop a
Tory brexit when Jeremy Corbyn is in
talks of Tory's made trying to get a
deal through surely when people taught
up the ledger they'll put the brakes
that party on one side and then they'll
put the Lib Dems change UK the Green
Party the SNP on the other yeah well I
mean that's a perfectly valid point I
think though it misses this point which
is one of reasons why if you listen to
what Nigel Farrar says he's very much
saying that Labour is essentially a
romaine party I think it's clear they're
not remain in an unequivocal sense but I
think there's enough in the labour case
that allows you still to vote Labour and
that's why I can vote Labour
in this election but you know the reason
I'm saying what I'm saying today is that
I understand there are a lot of people
would just say and I found this talking
to people they just say I'm sorry
Labour's been hopeless on the question
that breaks it I'm not prepared to do
that and what I say to them is well
don't stay at home because if you do
then that Pro Faraj hard or no deal
breaks it and that's what these guys are
in the people in the Conservative Party
like Boris Johnson are going for that is
a hard break suit or a No Deal breaks it
is an extreme position that will do
enormous damage to our country if you
care about stopping that get on the
other side of the ledger and I think
labor just gets there I mean this is
always as close as you could get as a
former Labour prime minister to telling
people to vote for other parties or them
the labour isn't it well look it's it's
a one-issue politics at the moment
effectively and what we could have
understand is if these people have their
way the hard or breaks it or no deal
breaks that people have their way we're
going to be doing nothing but breaks it
for the years to come I mean what we're
going to realize is that Nigel fragile
and the people associated with them
they're not the people to drain the
swamp of British politics they're the
people that have created this one
they've literally created this issue of
briggsie as if it's the answer to the
country's problems when it's literally
the answer to nothing and we will be we
have been obsessed with brags it for
three years we're going to be obsessed
with Briggs it for years to come unless
we come out and show equivocally that
they do not speak for Britain that there
are lots of people there who want us to
get this Briggs it thing resolved in a
sensible way that allows us to stay
within the European Union
and get on with dealing with the real
issues of the country the Health Service
climate change the economy knife crime
all the issues that are presently
absolutely relegated to the back burner
because of brexit I mean some supporters
of Nigel frosh would say that actually
the politicians who quoted this form are
the establishment politicians of the
last few decades such as yourself who
have ignored people's concerns on
immigration who ignored people's
concerns on globalization and that's why
we're in this situation absolutely this
is exactly what they say and that's why
they've got to be taken head-on because
when you actually analyze what they're
saying what what is Briggs that do for
the National Health Service the National
Health Service futures decided in
Britain it's not decided in Brussels
what does it say about our taxes we can
put our taxes up down do whatever we
work with public spending we'll put it
up put it down that is decided here in
the UK it's not decided in the European
Parliament if you take the issues for
example any of the things that really
concern people the communities left
behind inequality the decisions that
will
fact that are taken here the whole of
the brexit case is based on a myth that
we're not in control of our own country
and what Nigel fragile is people want to
do is to use this Briggs it issue
because they have a their own agenda
around the country they want to use it
to split the country over breaks it when
it's literally the answer to nothing so
you know yes I agree of course that what
they want to do is to say look there's
just no leader people who are stopping
you getting your way but get our way to
what I mean what is it that they believe
that brings it will offer us that allow
us to take this country forward
and if they get their way because you
know they're in a no deal position and
let's be clear what do they say about No
Deal No Deal no problem this is Nigel
Faraj and Boris Johnson so just analyze
that for a moment we are going to change
overnight with No Deal the trading terms
for hundreds of billions of pounds worth
of trade in the UK and there's going to
be no problem not some problem but we
can overcome at no problem that is such
an extreme position that it's necessary
now for people who are against that to
rally together so yes I agree it's a
very odd situation to be in when you
you're fighting a European election
campaign without really an effective
leader and without one party to vote for
I agree it's a very odd situation but it
still matters I mean you've described
the Labour Party position on brexit as
destructive indecision what do you mean
by that what I mean by that is look why
the two main parties imploding over
brexit and they're in the situation
where both of them are losing support
because there has been one fundamental
strategic fallacy at the heart of both
main parties position on brexit and that
is to believe that there's a compromised
form of briggsie that will satisfy and
bring together both sides of the country
and I'm afraid it's a fallacy because
the soft brings it that Teresa may has
tried to articulate and that in a sense
the Labour Party's official position has
been up to now it won't work and it
won't work for a very simple reason
because actually the whole
of the breaks it is is based on a myth
which is that we don't control our own
laws they have to target the laws of the
single market because it's true we've
agreed collectively to agree those with
the rest of Europe and therefore what
happens is if you end up with a brexit
compromise that is a soft bracelet which
is very well intentioned in its thinking
but you end up in a situation where
effectively you stay in the trading
system of the European Union abide by
its rules but have lost your seat at the
table that soft brakes it is never going
to command anything other than a tiny
support because the people who want
breaks it are going to say it's a
betrayal and the people like myself will
want to stay will say it's completely
pointless well let's have a look at and
what people do want we can have a look
at the latest poll shall we and about
the European elections and you can see
here I mean the BRICS at parties
absolutely topping the poll there
they've got more support than the Lib
Dems a green party and change UK
combined I mean do you look at this and
think actually you've got it wrong most
people don't want a second referendum
you know if you look at the 34% that is
and you could get higher than that but I
don't believe a majority of people think
Nigel Farrar speaks for the country I
really don't think that the question is
to the majority people want a second
referendum if you look at these polls
you have to say they don't well what you
have to say is it's the country is
deeply divided so here's here's because
sometimes when I say look another
referendum could be a healing process
people say well how can that possibly be
what we have to understand is the only
brexit that makes sense in the end is a
briggs it that appeals to briggs it ears
I mean let's agree there's absolutely no
point in doing a brexit that the people
who've advocated brakes that say is a
betrayer some people would say a brick
said at least it's respecting the
democracy of the referendum and also
potentially the European elections as
well the to clear votes we've had on
Europe because what you've just pointed
out is the party that's way ahead on
Briggs it is the Faraj party that's a
hard or no deal brexit so what there's
no point in thinking that you're you're
going to have people saying when you've
respected the 2016 referendum if you do
it breaks it that the very people who
advocate brexit say is
properly Briggs in this is why I say to
you in the end a soft Briggs it for
reasons you know I completely understand
why people are putting it forward it
looks like a smart sort of compromise
but in the end it falls apart because it
pleases no one that's why both main
parties are in the difficulty therein in
my view of labor had taken a strong
position right from the very beginning
which is to say okay we accept the
referendum result but we reserve the
right once we see the outcome of the
negotiations we reserve the right to put
it back to the people it would be in a
hugely stronger position today because
it would be hovering up all those votes
that are presently for the Liberal
Democrats the green change UK and you
haven't added in the SNP but I think
that's about 4% which actually adds up
to pretty much almost 30% so the point
is very very simple in the end what
should happen and this is what Theresa
May should have been doing months ago
but she could still do it even now the
government has got to grip this process
in Parliament it's got to set out the
true options which are hard soft or no
deal breaks it it's got to set them out
it's got to make Parliament come to a
decision and then Parliament will have
to decide once it decides on what forma
brexit does it attach a confirmatory
referendum to it and I think the moment
you force people to decide whether you
want hard soft or no deal brexit they
will realize in Parliament the sensible
thing is to share responsibility for
that huge decision with the British
people and in the course of that by the
way then I think you can get a healing
process because in the end you can
properly explore the arguments in a much
more informed way than we were able to
do back in June 2016 okay I just wanna
have a look at something you said
recently about the possibility of a
second independence referendum in
Scotland she said this I don't think we
should have one unless areas really is a
big groundswell of opinion for it and I
don't see that the last thing we need at
this moment is another huge dose of
constitutional uncertainty how can you
think that about a Scottish referendum
and yet be in favour of a second
referent and when there doesn't seem to
be that decisive groundswell of support
for it well I don't know that there
isn't oh there is a huge amount of
support for a second referendum whether
it's a majority or not it's absolutely
clear the
that there is strong support for listen
if there's a majority isn't it how can
you tell whether that you can't tell
ultimately whether it's a majority
unless you put it to the people but I
think the two things are completely
different we're about just imagine this
scenario supposing we know now go down
the route and let's be clear I mean I'm
afraid Teresa may is not going to be the
Conservative Party leader for much
longer
if the Conservative Party leader elected
leadership election now you're going to
get a competition in front of the small
number of people as to which candidate
can be more Pro brexit than the other
camp I don't you get I don't know I
think if she set out the right set of
options in the way I've described I
think she could stay to the end of the
process I think if she refuses to do
that look you know I'm not in charge of
the Tory Party it's gonna be very
difficult for her but the point is this
that in the end when you look at the
situation you're going to have this
fundamental division in the country it's
not the same as the Scottish
independence referendum because right
now we're deciding whether to do brexit
or not and the truth is if we end up
doing a hard or no deal breaks it and I
don't believe you can really justify
that by reference the June 2016 that
referendum particularly a No Deal breaks
it believe me you're gonna get a
revolution in British politics the other
way people talk about you know how you
you have to avoid those who feel
strongly Pro brexit you have to avoid
them writhing on the streets and and you
know this outbursts of populism okay I
understand that and that's why you've
got to handle this issue I agree very
very carefully but let me just tell you
this if we go ahead and tumble out of
the European Union with a No Deal break
set of the sort that frosh and Boris
Johnson these people won you are going
to get a silent revolution in this
country as well there are going to be
people who are going to feel so strongly
about this that I just say this to both
main political parties they're gonna
sweep them away it's interesting
listening to you talk like this silent
revolution about the kind of the
groundswell of huge feeling on both
sides of the argument and it feels up to
me it's well actually you know when you
go around talk to be from different part
of our country it's it's the trust and
politics and the frustration and there
is so intense
I mean are you actually concerned about
when the dust is settled on what we do
with brexit what are the long-term
consequences going to be of this trust
in politics and also potentially in
democracy as well I think we have
divided our country in a very deep way
and I don't think you can reconcile the
country over brexit per se I think what
you could do is get to a situation where
if as I hope we we still escape bread
said you then have to deal with those
issues around immigration around
communities and people who feel their
casualties of globalization are
beneficiaries of it you have to deal
with those issues that's why I'm not in
a position of saying look you know the
concerns that underlay brexit are
irrelevant concerns or they don't matter
I'm still absolutely in the position of
saying no if you make some mistakes then
because you're talking there about you
know people who are the casualties of
globalization I mean really when you're
a prime minister you were the great
advocate of globalization weren't you
multiculturalism yeah and I still am a
big advocate of globalization but you
have to make sure that those people who
do not feel that they've got the same
opportunities as those happy with this
process of globalization and looked
after enough we put the biggest and
largest investment into public services
this country seen since the Second World
War we introduced for the first time a
minimum wage in the country we made
massive investments in the inner city
but when you when you when you search
your son by the way did you do enough to
try and address people's concerns on
these issues well you know the easy
thing for me to say is the way know if
we should have done more and so on but
frankly when I left office in 2007 in
this country in terms of its public
realm and in terms of the investment and
change we were putting into communities
it was huge now had I still been in
office I mean people often say about
immigration yes but you let the the the
European migrants come in in 2004 when
these countries from the east joined the
European Union okay we can have a debate
about that but when people say for
example we didn't we weren't concerned
with immigration it's just rewriting
history
we had legislation on reducing
the numbers of asylum seekers I actually
left office with a whole process in
place around identity cards necessary to
keep a strong check who come into the
country who couldn't come into the
country why is it that a banjo Faraj is
that politician who's managed to tap
into people's concerns on globalization
or on the mistrust in the establishment
why is it him who's managed to address
those concerns and not politicians from
the centigrams such as yourself well
that's a really good question and the
answer is because we stopped addressing
those questions and all the way through
if you want to win Paulo if you want to
win from the center ground you've got to
address the underlying anxieties that
people have and that's why I say to you
if we end up because Briggs that is the
answer to none of the problems in
constituencies like mine in the north of
England if you end up changing brexit
you've got to combine that with measures
that deal with their underlying concerns
and by the way there's a much better
chance of dealing with those concerns in
Europe as a whole today because if you
take something like freedom of movement
to people there's a huge concern across
the whole of Europe today it's not just
a British problem on immigration it's
clear that's a it's a pending European
politics no the reason why we're in this
position is that the center ground
stopped dealing with the concerns that
people have and if you don't deal with
those concerns they then are prey to the
type of populist rhetoric that people
like Nigel Farage from Boris Johnson
pursue when actually the politics that
people like Nigel Farage represent offer
nothing to these people I mean if you if
you're in the north of England you're
worried about your community being left
behind plus breaks it gonna do for you
it's just gonna make your problems worse
you see it sounds like a very convincing
argument for the center ground and the
strength of the center ground but just
wonder if your analysis is ten years
out-of-date
I mean as politics changed its identity
politics now isn't it yep the thing
about politics is it doesn't stay in one
place and you've got to give people
leadership look identity politics of
course your sense of identity matters
but the fact is what is driving
globalization just to turn to that for a
moment what's driving globalization is
the real world it's not government's
that are driving it it's technology it's
and travel it's mass migration which is
happy
all over the world the question is not
how you stop globalization because it's
not possible to stop it it's how you
make sense of it and make it work for
people and let's be clear if for example
the world embarks on a new system of
protectionism it becomes anti-free trade
you know exposing we withdrawal from the
the single market that's not gonna help
that if you look at the world that is
what it's putting aside whether it's
right or wrong that is happening you
know you're getting nationalist populist
strongmen leaders across the world I
mean do you think Donald Trump
understands the 21st century better than
you do
no I think he what he understands is
there's a big opportunity in exploiting
that division and what I understand is
unless you deal with the underlying
causes of division you won't defeat that
populism but you can defeat it and by
the way you're right I mean the
Democrats in the u.s. face exactly the
same choices as the Labour Party here if
you go off to the the left and you stop
talking to people in the center then
those people in the center can then
gravitate towards the right because as I
always say to people if you end up with
a populist left fighting a populist
right the populist right will win a
change UK have tried to build a politics
from the centre and they've had some
teething problems to say the least you
know they're polling poor they haven't
even standing a candidate in
Peterborough are you talking to change
UK I've talked to the the people who are
in change UK a lot yeah and a lot of
what they say I sympathize with but you
know leave aside whether they've got
supported they don't have support you've
also got to look at the position of the
Labour Party today we've just had local
elections local elections any opposition
party can win local elections I mean in
the 3040 years I've been in politics no
matter how difficult the position of an
opposition party is when you go into
local elections you can be pretty sure
of winning those we didn't even win them
so Labour's also got a lot of thinking
to do about where it places itself
whether it's got an agenda that actually
meets the challenges now future now I
think at the moment it doesn't I mean
the single biggest challenge that we are
going to face as a country the world is
facing at the moment is the
technological revolution it's literally
the twenty-first century equivalent of
the 19th century Industrial Revolution
how we deal with that how we access its
opportunities mitigate its its problems
and its displacement of jobs and so on
that is the central question of politics
when I am talking about that in the UK
today you know this is what is so
frustrating and depressing about Briggs
it it's not just the destructive impact
it's the distractive impact it's the
fact that when these huge challenges are
coming down the line you've got the
entire political energy of the country
something that breaks it okay okay we're
out of time thank you very much for
being on the program today